e
good morning everyone I'm going to call
to order a committee of conference for
House Bill
458 now this is a bill
that was a significant change from the
original House Bill
458 that was a bill that was designed to
do something something completely
different but a Senate Bill had
superseded it so the house amended House
Bill 458 to reestablish a commission to
to study the assessing of power
generation this is a commission that was
established at least a year ago maybe
two years ago it had done some work but
it didn't finish the work that they were
trying to accomplish so they asked us to
and then the committee the commission
EXP spired so they asked us to
reestablish the commission so that they
could finish their
work so that's what the substance of the
bill
did and when we sent the bill to the
Senate after it passed the house the
Senate decided to make
a a change an
amendment to solve one problem and
here's the
problem right
now power General generators power plant
assessment so that when they're trying
to figure out what their tax assessment
is going to be they have to talk to the
Dr and then they have to talk to one or
more private assessor is usually hired
by a
municipality and this creates a lot of
confusion and it also leads to to a lot
of lawsuits which ends up costing
everybody more
money so the Senate changed the language
in the bill to try to eliminate this
multiple points of
assessment and create just a single
point of assessment for a power
generation plant to deal with
and the board of assessment came to me
and said they preferred the house
language but looking at the house
language and comparing it to the Senate
language it seems to me that the
original House language is
quite vague and
confusing so we think we would be
willing to go along with the Senate
Amendment with a slight
change the current Senate Amendment for
Section D reads recommend a solution for
Power Generation generation assets to
face a single point of assessment
commensurate with market-based
commercial
property we feel if we changed the three
words at the beginning of that sentence
recommendations that that would allow
the commission to analyze all different
strategies for coming methodologies for
coming up with an
assessment and then come up with a
recommendation or possibly more
recommendations to put together a single
point of
assessment so that's the proposal I
think we would like to ask the Senate to
consider and I would open the floor to
other members of the committee to
discuss this further representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman um were you
also considering in that amended
language that you just mentioned adding
the single
point language to that because I you
didn't mention that you mentioned
changing the sentence at the beginning
to say create recommendations so what
I'm recommending is that we go to the
Senate if you look at the uh side by
side and change the first three words
yes okay gotcha just change the first
three words because that preserves the
language about a single point of
assessment perfect thank you okay
further
discussion
good that's good good okay the Senate
agrees with um
this recommendation that we change those
three words to the two words create
recommendations and the house
members I believe we agree to that as
well okay good I think we're done it's
only
910 Mr chairman yeah let's keep let's up
the next two go as quickly and uh since
we have two at 1 9:30 we'll get back up
here shortly after 9 okay all right for
the all right with that I'm going to
adjourn this Committee of conference and
thank all members for your participation
thank
you
e
to order the committee of conference on
1623 for the house we have
Representatives Harrington Bernardi and
Thomas and myself of course and for the
Senate we have Senate enr chairman
Senator Kevin
avard Senator David Waters and joining
us shortly will be Senator Howard Pearl
I
believe he is at another uh Committee of
conference working on lithium batteries
Mr
chairman was scheduled at the same time
yeah
so we're here to discuss the changes
made by the Senate to House Bill
1623 the Senate removed quite a bit of
the language that was in the original
Bill essentially all of the language
down
to section
two a language that involved War
findings
and the language that involved changes
to RSA 378 colon
37 which is the New Hampshire State
energy
policy the Senate left intacted the
section of the bill that
discussed loss of instate electrical
generation and provided a remedy about
what to do with
that so I'm here this morning on on
behalf of the house because the house
position was the entire Bill to advocate
for adding some new language to the
bill I recognized that the original
Bill's complete replacement of RSA 378
colon 37 was probably too much to
ask so this amended version that I'm
morning retains all of the original
language from 378 col
37 doesn't change a single letter of the
existing
language of that portion of the statute
all it does is add some additional
language to that portion of the
statute
to place an emphas emphasis
on some important
Concepts the
major Concepts that it tries to enshrine
in statute are
reliability and low consumer prices and
price
stability when I talk to my
constituents they complain a little bit
about the price of electricity but the
thing they complain the most about is
it's
reliability why does it take so long for
the power company to get my power back
on when it goes off when a storm passes
through why do I have power outages
every week etc etc that's the single
biggest complaint that I hear when I
talk to my constituents about
electricity
so I think it's important for us to
emphasize in state energy policy that
reliability is a key
component of everything we do and that's
why the four of us on the house side
have worked together to put together
this amendment
proposal and I would like to hear from
other members of the committee of
conference to get your reaction to this
proposal representative
Harrington yeah just to reemphasize what
the chairman just said I think that uh
you know it sounds kind of silly but
during a power routage I've had people
say I'll rent your generator I don't
care what it cost because reliability is
such an important thing um my daughter
who has her own business uh lives out
used to live in California and she would
lose the power in the summertime on a
semi-regular basis which caused her to
move out of California she just couldn't
tolerate having that loss and as we go
forward we liability is going to be a
much much bigger issue and we need to
look at the big picture on this we've
seen a lot of proposals for New
Generation but very few of them come
online um in the last uh year I think
we've seen five offshore wind projects
cancelled from New Jersey through New
England uh it's one in New Jersey just
paid $120 million fine rather than build
to their contract that they signed one
in Massachusetts paid a $65 million fine
so reliability is going to be the key
issue people about my French but
that's what they do about cost but when
it comes down to it if they don't have
electricity they're willing to pay
double the price to get it back so we
got to start with reliability that's the
most important
thing representative Thomas thank you Mr
chair uh again I will Echo with the last
two speakers sentiments and add that for
my constituents in
lary yes reliability is paramont and I
would say extremely important to our uh
our our businesses but lary has a very
high percentage of elderly and families
on fixed incomes and price and price
stability are Paramount to them as well
so I think it's very important that we
set up a policy where yes reliability is
first always has to be you have to have
reliable power no matter what you do but
also pricing and price stability is very
important particularly for our elderly
and people on fixed income
uh they just with with inflation going
on right now they just can't afford more
price likes and I think we need to be
very sensitive to that and I think the
state needs to follow a policy that
follows the best interests of these
constituents representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair I'll I'll
third the motion uh the key language you
have in here uh in this particular
amendment is affordability reliability
and price stability those are key
elements to ensure uh that we address in
energy policy and they hit all the
points of our constituents they want the
prices known and they want that
electricity reliable and they want it
reasonable in
cost Senator
Waters uh thank you Mr chairman um
we have passed uh House Bill 1431 on uh
transmission planning and we have
created a uh grid modernization working
group a couple years ago and uh I think
that we have good systems in place to
deal with reliability of uh transmission
and distribution um and I think that the
Senate would like to uh stay with the
Senate position on the bill and hope
that the house would exceed to that
chairman I concur with any further
Waters okay so is it the Senate's
position that they will not consider
this amendment language that is the
Senate's
position we have there's no room for
discussion no room for we do like what
you modifications to this language we do
like what is the remainder of the of of
the bill though and we uh we feel that
uh that sovereignty piece is is very
very important and uh we definitely
would Embrace that
wholeheartedly but at this time I think
any uh any changes or uh we're we're
pretty much
uh of one mind not to uh to amend it
could you help us understand what about
this language you don't like either of
you uh
well I think it uh there there is a a
bit of vaguery here with this uh limited
to the intervenes economic advantages
it's not very
specific and
uh I just I I just feel it's too vague
at this point and I think what we have
right now I haven't heard anything about
reliability uh for my consumers and for
my constituents at this price definitely
prices are are are concerned but uh
allowing more more uh renewable energies
uh projects that we're working on right
now I think is is is trying to address
that but um at this point I think just
it's it's kind of vague so I mean that's
this Senator Waters yeah thanks Mr
chairman so I agree with the the chair
um and I also would just say in a big
picture we have gotten just an enormous
amount done on energy policy over the
last couple of years years and I I think
that um we're ending up in a very good
place with what the Senate did to Senate
bill to House Bill 16 uh 23 and as I
said I think that there certainly will
be things to continue discussing in
subsequent sessions but uh it is our
hope that the um because there is as the
chairman said some some substance that's
important to uh the version of House
Bill 1623 that the Senate passed and we
would hope that the house um for this
year could live with letting that be
what we do and conversations would
continue so Senator avard you mentioned
um some what you consider to be vague
language about economically Advantage
One technology over
another would it change your opinion of
this suggested language if the phrase
that starts on line three with the words
to limit and ends on line five with
specific policy goal if that phrase was
struck would the rest of the language be
acceptable to either of
you I I think uh at this point we we're
anything so you won't even consider that
no sir but thank you for asking all
right representative Thomas thank you Mr
chair so uh to be clear um Sen
I could you help me understand a little
bit
more why you have
a um reservation on
wanting uh people's energy to be
reliable and lower cost and to be stable
I I I I don't can you help me understand
why that phrase seems to be offensive uh
to to the senate i
I'd be glad to just say senator Waters I
think we'd be very happy to continue
discussions next session um and I I I
don't think that our objection to this
at this point in time should be assumed
to have any principle or of what the
representative has just suggested so um
I as I said I hope that uh the house can
understand the Senate position um of
sticking with its verion and um that
that's where we're at at and uh so
that's the decision I think is up to the
house is what you want to do Senator
aard yeah I I I have no objections to uh
lowering uh energy costs and and
producing reliability I think the the
key part of this bill that I'm I'm very
keen on on passing is the you know the
protection of law fair and I think uh
and I applaud you for that that part of
this bill and I think that at this point
uh that is one key element of this bill
that'll help uh lower the cost and and
keep reliability there because people
will not be engaged in Endless lawsuits
and I think that is a good part of this
bill and I I support it
wholeheartedly uh so I think that's kind
of where I'm at right now so it's not
like we're definitely for lower prices
we're definitely for reliability so to
not not agree with that part of the bill
does not mean that we are against it it
just means that this is the part of the
wholeheartedly okay anybody else have
anything to add representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair I guess I do
not understand that statement it's I
understand the law fair section of the
bill makes perfect sense but I don't
understand why making a public policy
statement that we want energy
reliability price affordability and
price stability
is not good for New Hampshire it just
comments okay seeing none I'm going to
call for a five minute break and I'm
going to ask the house members to meet
me in this office right over here for a
quick
discussion
e
like to resume this Committee of
conference on how Bill
1623 house conre have made a decision
about what we would like to do and I
recognize representative Thomas thank
you Mr chair Mr chair um although I I do
think it's extremely important that the
state make a statement on the policy of
energy reliability looking for the low
cost and to protect price stability it
does trouble me that we can't seem to
get that language in to this bill
however the second part of this bill is
also very important and it does protect
or helps to protect our generators and
sends a strong message to others outside
of us of the state here that um that we
want to protect our power generators the
ones that we have so I believe it's
worth keeping this bill uh with the
Senate's position and that I expect uh
that that there will be new uh
legislation and discussions coming
forward next year to uh make this bill
even better make this statute even
better so uh with that uh I uh somewhat
um uh reluctantly but I believe that
this a step in the right direction and I
will be supporting the Senate
Amendment representative
Arrington yeah without repeating
everything that uh representative Thomas
just said I complete agreement with them
I think uh sometimes you got to look at
it and say well a step in the right
direction is better than no Step at all
though I think uh the original bill was
better I'm willing to go along with this
with the idea that if I am reelected uh
this discussion we'll be back again next
year representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair yes I I
would concur uh half a loaf here is uh
better than uh no loaf at all it's the
uh the lawfare provisions are very
important particularly with respect to
our discussions in uh the greater uh New
England area uh but it's also important
for us in the future to strive for a
policy that enshrines reliability
affordability thank
you so as you probably have surmised the
house position is going to be that we
will acceed to the Senate changes to
this
bill do you have anything to add thank
you okay so we are done and I will make
sure that this information gets
transmitted to OS and the house clerk
thank you all and we'll see you again at
conference
e
the committee of conference on House
Bill
1600 representing the house this morning
is representative Corman representative
McGee representative Thomas and myself
representative Michael Vose representing
the Senate is Senator Howard Pearl
Senator David Waters and I'm told that
Senator Kevin avard will be joining us
in a few minutes or as soon as he can
get
away so we're here this morning to
discuss House Bill 1600 an act relative
to participation in net energy meeting
metering
sorry the bill that we sent that the
Senate was a two-section bill that
basically made Municipal
hosts who want to participate in
community aggregation to be a member of
the community
aggregation the Senate after listening
to some
concerns from the Department of energy
and some others decided to change the
bill to remove that section of the bill
and to change it into a study committee
a committee that shall examine
legislative options regarding regulation
of aggregation of electric customers by
municipalities and counties including
treatment of Municipal hosts pursuant to
RSA 362a col
92 so the position of the
to make the change that allowed
these Municipal hosts to be part of a
community
aggregation at the time that the house
made that decision which I believe
passed on the consent calendar
unanimously out of committee and then on
the consent calendar in the house at the
time of that
passage the facts on the ground seem to
indicate that this was a
non-controversial
item subsequently by the time the bill
got to the Senate numerous objections
had been raised and
concerns concerning some possible
unintended
consequences and I paid close attention
as did many of the members of this
committee our committee science
technology and energy to the debate in
the
Senate and many of those concerns seemed
legitimate
so we're here this morning to discuss
what should be the path
forward and I would like to recognize my
house colleagues to discuss what they
think we should do for this bill so I'll
turn first to representative Corman who
is the Prime sponsor of this
legislation thank you very much Mr
chairman uh I introduced this bill at
the request of the Community power
Coalition and as uh chairman Bose said
it passed St in the house unanimously
passed on consent and then went to the
Senate where uh energy and natural
resources heard the bill when Department
of energy testified on the bill at St
and at enr they testified that they were
neutral and then shortly uh Before the
bill was exec in Ian hour uh we received
a letter from Tom France and Chris Elms
with their concerns about the
bill and um these concerns actually
chairman Vose listed in his floor speech
last week in the house when we discussed
this
bill the community power Coalition in
fact the chair uh Clifton Belo who's
sitting in the
back did send Tom frons a response to to
the points that he raised and Mr Belo
responded in detail to each one of the
concerns raised by the department of
energy so I understand that that this
part of the bill the first part of the
bill is is in Jeopardy but my own
feeling is that these concerns actually
have already been answered and we we
should go forward with the house version
of the
bill couple of things I want to say
one is that when the bill was introduced
to Senate enr Mr Belo also included or
uh uh suggested an amendment um with a
minor language change that addressed a
concern that Doe had expressed at that
point um and that that particular
Amendment did not make it through and
the second thing I want to say is that
the Senate Amendment which creates a
study committee uh I would not favor
that at all and the reason is that I
don't think we need one and by the time
it actually would be formed and um
operating it would be very late in the
cycle with a report due on November 1st
I could see this committee not even
getting formed until September and that
just doesn't give much time and there
actually is one other thing I want to
say which is section two of the house
bill no matter what we do we should at
least get get section two approved
because that's just a simple
housekeeping change that I don't think
there's any objection to so those are
the points I want to make thank you for
recognizing me Mr chairman
representative
McGee thank you Mr
chairman um what I would like to say is
I would like to take us back to those
happy days when the house was in
uh was in agreement that this was a good
bill to pass uh and basically talk about
the reason for section one of the
bill um we enabled uh competition in the
market with HB
3155 and when I saw this bill and I was
a co-sponsor on it when I saw the
language in this bill basically it it
also is housekeeping it's trying to make
sure that the community power Coalition
is able to become to partner with
Municipal hosts and that those
definitions are clarified in the
language of the RSA and I think all of
us on on house science technology and
energy agreed that that was language
that should be there to enable those
Partnerships which I don't know about
the rest of you but when we past
315 that is what I imagined Community
power would be going out and doing um
helping to leverage those local
community projects in order to bring
people's costs down um by accessing
accessing power near where they're using
it so I looked at this as a followon
step that made a lot of
sense and when I heard that there was a
letter saying don't do anything with
this bill um I went to sort of see what
the concerns from doe were and I know we
have we have someone from DOA here today
that will maybe answer questions if we
have any um and I read the letter and
what I saw was I don't want to call it a
smoke screen but I what I saw was a
letter that was um alleging that there
were a lot of things that were
unknown um many of those unknowns that
they alluded to were covered by the
Inception of the community power
Coalition with 315 and are already in
Statute in many places the one thing
that I saw that was pointed to that is
an open question is sort of what's
happening on some existing people UC
dockets but when those dockets are
resolved they will be taking into
consideration the fact that Community
power uh is operating in you know in the
environment that we have today for um
Power suppliers
so I I think that the original um
purpose of the bill has not changed and
that the delay is
unnecessary without
[Music]
some objection that that
actually um can be Quantified um because
it it it does feel like it's sort of
being
derailed the the other argument that I
think was thrown out was a concern for
cost shifting and in speaking with the
folks at Community power um what is in
this bill says that any Financial
transactions that happen between the
municipal host and Community power are
between those parties it has nothing to
do with the default um provider so so
rate payers uh of the utilities would
not be affected in any way by any of
these uh private contracts so I'm trying
to figure out what it is we're trying to
stop by um changing our position on the
original Bill uh that sailed through the
house because it was a good a good bit
legislation I know you said you didn't
want to uh accuse this bill of being a
smokescreen but you did which is
probably not appropriate so let's try to
keep that in mind as we make comments uh
going forward it's not appropriate to
malign the motivation or the intentions
of a state department representative
Thomas thank you Mr chair um well first
of all I agree that the the section two
technical housekeeping is um you know a
uh something that normally happens in a
build when we find that just for
technical reasons we have to make a
housekeeping change I don't have any
problem with that um but as in sometimes
you know in the fury of having public
hearings in the house uh you know bills
get passed and then because we think
it's it's it's a good bill but then
sometimes as time goes by and you hear
other arguments coming from the other
side of the curtain um you know you
start to wonder gee maybe there was
something we didn't quite understand and
so I'm beginning to think that you know
in this particular case uh the wisdom of
the uh of our friends on on the other
side to maybe step back and have a study
committee just might be in order for
something complicated as what's uh going
on here so I would be more inclined to
agree with um the chair that perhaps
this might be the better course of
action in this particular case because
sometimes
sometimes we think something is really
good and and then maybe after a while we
discover well we hadn't thought about
something and perhaps we need to step
back so I'd be more inclined to uh to
side as uh a press release from the
governor's office a week or so ago
pointed
out New Hampshire has done a very good
job of
managing what some people refer to as a
trans transition in the energy
economy and we've done that by paying
close
attention to what things
cost and what the unintended
consequences of policies might
be the result of all that is that energy
costs have been rising in New Hampshire
much more slowly than they have been
rising in the five other New England
states
and the difference is the direct result
of the policy
made so I know the governor's office and
the department of energy want to take a
very careful and balanced
approach to how we
Implement policies to
with an eye toward
protecting the people who have to pay
essentially so initially that's why I
thought maybe a study committee might be
appropriate to try to far it
out whether this proposed legislative
change would cost people
money probably not utility rate payers
but maybe Community power Coalition rate
paays and to be
forthcoming I am chair of the eping
energy aggregation committee and the
town of eping will become is a community
power Coalition member and will launch
our own Community power uh program on
October 1 of this year so that's my full
disclosure with with regard to community
power
so I was initially uh persuaded that a
study committee might be a
worthwhile
project but then I received email from
the director of regulatory and
legislative affairs at the community
power Co
Coalition who said that and this is a
quote from the email we request that
there not be a study committee included
in such an agreement on quote and as
representative Corman uh has already
indicated the chance of this study
committee producing a significant
outcome seem to be
slim given the fact that this is the
second year of a
banum in the fall people are going to be
distracted by their own campaigns for
reelection if they
are amounting such a
campaign so I now feel that a study
committee might not be the best way to
go for this particular bill I do think
it's important to save the technical
correction that's in section two of the
bill but beyond that I think um there's
not much else we can do this
bym and we have to hope that we
can work harder next year to come up
with a uh strategy to fulfill the
requirements of
proposal so the senate representative
watus you have something to add to our
conversation thanks Mr chairman and uh I
I just want to start off by saying how
much um it's appreciated all the house
has done on community power and um the
vvus of ideas sitting in the back there
around this that we will have lots of
chances discussed in the future so I I I
do think that the chairman um suggest
that it's good to good to get section
two to on a technical fix and if that's
what we do to save the bill maybe that's
a good way to go is that fair enough Mr
chairman yeah so I I think that that's
what we could agree on is um uh to uh
amended version of just section
two okay representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman since we have folks here in
the audience who've come to the hearing
um I I I'd like to take us just briefly
to what what we're actually discussing
for those who are watching at home the
language that we're discussing not
implementing that sailed through the
house is when a municipal host as
defined in RSA 362 consents to use its
generation to offset the group load of a
municipal or County aggregation and not
one or more individual retail customer
accounts then it shall be a customer of
a municipal or County aggregation and
not on utility default service with
compensation for their output made
pursuant to RSA
362 so what we're saying is we can't
agree that a group that we empowered in
order to provide competition in the
energy Market that pretty much all of
our towns are currently engaging with um
that we can't allow them to enter into
this type of relationship because we're
not sure how it will turn out when that
is exactly what we asked them to do when
we decided to put them into business in
the state I I feel like it's a one step
forward two steps back what we're doing
to them because they've got Municipal
hosts lined up that they're looking to
work with and that has everything to do
with whether or not they can bring down
costs right they're not they're not
magicians they're asking us to
enable Partnerships that should have
been defined when we passed 315 but we
didn't think of them you know we didn't
think to include that language so that's
why I said I thought section one was
also a housekeeping item and I'm still
haven't heard maybe we should hear from
doe what objections
or cost
concerns uh could get in the way of us
being able to pass this now rather than
delaying I I know there's been a lot of
conversation about the easiest thing to
do is just pass section two and be done
with it but I came here today hoping
that we would have a more fome
conversation about the goal of this bill
um because again it's a one step forward
two steps back for a business a
nonprofit that's trying to create
competition in our energy Market to
lower costs that's what we ask them to
do that's what we celebrated when we
passed 315 and now they're coming back
to us saying this type of a relationship
is something that we should be enabl to
do and it should should be in statute so
that it's clear how that works and we're
saying this clear language this simple
language about this relationship we
can't figure it out and I I just
fundamentally disagree with that I think
I think it's it is as simple as it looks
so I'm just throwing it out there
okay further comment representative
Corbin thank you uh to what
representative McGee just said I would
add one other thing which is one of the
objections that Doe raised was what
happens when there are multiple
utilities involved and the amendment
that Mr Belo suggested to the senate enr
committee actually took care of that and
and said that all the customers
comprising the load being offset are you
located in the same utility service
territory so that particular objection
could have been answered had the Senate
considered that particular
Amendment okay thank you any further
comments from anyone all right I'm going
to call a five minute recess and ask
house conferees to join me in that
little room right over there we'll be
minutes
e
we are going to resume the committee of
conference
on House Bill
1600 and I am going to move
that this Committee of conference adopt
an amendment to the entire bill that
preserves the content of section two of
the original House
Bill and section three the effective
date of the original House bill that
Amendment would of course renumber these
two sections to one and
two do I have a second to that motion
seconded by Senator Waters any if I may
Senator Purl I believe procedurally you
have to vote on it and then we have to
vote on it separately so I think you
your second would have to come from the
house side okay sorry about that so do I
have a second from the member of from a
member of the House Representative
Thomas seconds my motion so just us four
house members have to vote on this so
can I have a
uh call of the role can you do that
representative Thomas representative
Corman yes representative McGee yes
representative Thomas yes representative
OES yes now the
Senate all in favor
I no roll call from you guys huh okay
all right so we're all agreed that we
will preserve sections two and three of
the house p last version of this bill
and um rumber them one and two and we're
done and I thank you all for your
participation in this Committee of